that's heavyweight champion Deontay
Wilder ringing the closing bell at the
New York Stock Exchange Wednesday and as
you can see breaking the gavel in the
process
Wilders earned a fearful reputation for
his power in the boxing ring and he
plans to use it tonight in an
electrifying title defense against
Dominic Brazil at the Barclays Center in
Brooklyn New York but what happens to
all that power and intimidation outside
the ring we recently found out
[Applause]
heavyweight champion Deontay Wilder has
proclaimed himself the baddest man on
this planet an apt description earned 1
knockouts at a time
[Applause]
Darrell what's it like when you land a
knockout punch the fear that power you
know the velocity that's coming from my
fist to hit his face to meet that right
there and to see the reaction that
happens at the hardest hit a punch in
boxing periods and while he prides
himself on that reputation with his
bronze bomber nickname
spend a little time with the six seven
powerhouse babies and you'll see boxing
is just one part of wilder and the title
he seems to relish most his dad outside
of boxing I'm a homebody I'm a true
homebody and I love being around my
family I love being around my mind my
kids and I love telling I tell him I
love them about six or seven times a day
you mean his the dichotomy that is
Deonte a mix of peace and ruthless power
which he says has been within him all
along my mom was saying it was a
Tasmanian devil but I was quiet I was I
was very I was I was to myself the
second oldest of four kids raised in
Tuscaloosa Alabama the place he still
calls home Wilder dreamt of playing
basketball or football for the Alabama
Crimson Tide and while he grew up poor
one thing he was rich in family and with
that came faith we had a lot of love my
entire family was based out of love you
know I'm a pastor's child as well too so
pastors branch at the past against
Wilders father Gary was and still is a
preacher in Tuscaloosa any memories that
come back to you
almost definitely you know just send up
in the pulpit you know I always talk
about the you know the passion that he
had when he preached
[Music]
your son is the heavyweight champ
yeah you work in a house of God
absolutely people don't see those two
things connected correct correct what do
you think there is a connection as a
spiritual connection and you know things
that are Spears you're gonna be unseen
although he was a man of God stuff he
didn't believe in not defending yourself
now we're gonna let nobody bully you
we had the guard in that's two but we
also had the other side as well faith
and strength which Wilder relied upon
when at age 19 he found out he was going
to be a father for the first time I must
admit it was very scary the ball game is
different when when your child is not
healthy that child would be born with
spina bifida meeting her spinal cord
wouldn't be developed properly sometimes
God though you test this in there
because that's what I like and it has it
was a test for me did you think at any
point of just walking away Danny you
said that I shut my that's down my heart
like I couldn't ever imagine my daughter
not being here you know that's my that's
my word that's that's the foundation to
start to it all you know me Wilders
daughter nyaaa is 14 now she's thrived
despite doctors fears but before she was
born
Wilder had no way of knowing how much
medical or physical help she would need
just that he would be the one to provide
it in deciding you need to take care of
your child mm-hmm how did boxing become
that answer I brought our boxing for the
simple fact that I you know I was
looking at the money you know aspect of
it I was ignorant to the sport I thought
every fighter stepped in the ring made a
lot of money you know what was it like
the first time getting in there first
off when I walk to the gym no luck when
I walked into the I heard two heavenly
sounds you know all the bags being hid
be banned because I've never seen this
I'm in Tuscaloosa Alabama things you
know boxing gear the first time he got
between the ropes why
admits he was like Bambi trying to get
his footing and teach his body how to be
a fighter but he was driven by a promise
made to then 1 year old nya I had
nowhere else to watch her while I was in
the gym and I just I remember coming to
down pat on my back said oh that's ok
baby
don't worry daddy's gonna be the
heavyweight champion of the world one
day and he's gonna be able to support
you beyond your belief you know man
she's just looking at me I was not
knowing that thing that I'm talking
about since putting on his first pair of
boxing gloves it would take Wilder about
a decade to get a shot at the
heavyweight title but he never forgot
that promise
[Applause]
On January 17th 2015
Deontay Wilder was crowned WBC
heavyweight world champion I know you
watching this man I promise you when you
was one years older that'll be world
champion
and we'd have been through a lot man
then Here I am daddy coming home with
that Bell baby so what was that moment
like it was an amazing moment because I
had so much weighing in on that just
like man I did it you know it's just I
feel enough setting a goal and no matter
what just going through so much at age
29
Wilder became the first American
heavyweight champ in nearly ten years
and now the big paydays he promised his
daughter are his reality this was your
way out your way to a better life man
but it doesn't mean it's who you are as
a person exactly right on here don't
mean Who I am
I love to fight now keeping around I'm a
nice guy I can whip some ass okay that's
what I am that's what I am every bit of
it Wow simply put right now
nyeeehhh is now the oldest of seven kids
that Wilder has me talks about how he
does everything for them I was teasing
him because he said you know the gold
change the cars those are for them I'm
like but you'll enjoy them for a little
while which obviously he does but it's
really obvious his passion is about his
children the thing he regrets the most
is this career that he has sometimes
keeps him from their events because he
draws so much attention and when we were
there that happened to him you could see
the hurt in his eyes about that is he
the answer to making boxing an American
sport again you know I'm Michelle I
don't even know if there is an answer to
that because MMA sort of cloud that
water you know or muddies the water I
should say but he's an exciting fighter
to watch and if the idea is that we want
a heavyweight champion in an American
one he is the answer right now